yes salut cents chambres aujourd'hui
j'ai une excellente nouvelle pour vous
puisque je vous faire gagner des coques
rhino chine
alors il ya plein de coke elles sont
pour vous et pour ça la fleur participe
à un petit concours alors vous allez
voir c'est super simple je vais tout
vous dire dans quelques secondes
juste à temps plein
dans la famille rhinochill je veux les
coques solide suite
alors vous en avez pas mal de
différentes émissions ce qu'on va faire
tout de suite c'est qu'on va regarder up
à quoi elle ressemble je vais vous
expliquer comment les gagner parce que
ces coques
elles sont pour vous et puis pour les
perdants vous allez voir à la fin il ya
quand même un petit truc pour vous voilà
faut que vous inquiétez pas le concours
par à partir d'aujourd'hui et ce jusqu'à
la fin du mois de juin 2018 donc ça vous
laisse un petit peu de temps toutes les
modalités sont précisées en bas dans la
description vous invite à aller les voir
alors on va commencer au sud par jeter
un petit coup d'oeil au niveau de ces
coques rhinochill parce que moi au
vraiment très jolie alors vous avez
celle la toute première je vais vous la
sorte elle a un effet wow amat je trouve
vraiment sympa inochi l'école est connu
pour faire des coque résistante et
solide donc ça devrait franchement de
faire donc là vous avez votre joli petit
coq
ça c'est un effet bois vous avez ensuite
là là vous avez celle là qui est un
effet carbone qui est très sympa aussi
ensuite dans la famille rhino sheed je
vais avoir celle là blanc tout simple
blanc mat très sympa ensuite hop celle
là comment on peut la décrire la c6 tout
neuf c'est un petit gris un petit gris
fort sympathique très joli donc on off
celle là est en fuite vers le meilleur
pour la fin
ma préférée c'est celle là avec un effet
bois un peu boisclair un peu bois
norvégien
je trouve ça très joli ces types comme
vous pouvez les gagner si vous avez un
smartphone présent dans la liste ici à
savoir il n'y a pas beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de smartphones mais
sans couvre quand même pas mal iphone
7,7 +88 plus et l'iphone 10 un galaxy s
9 s9 plus la suze iphone le 5 et le 5 z
d'ailleurs on va tester le succès d'ici
quelques jours donc le rester connecté
abonnez vous le google pixels 2
2x et puis le web et 20 alors rassurez
vous je pense notamment à tous ceux qui
ont des iphone ils sont pas hyper hyper
hyper récents comme moi moi j'ai ainsi
16 qui est là le 6 aces va passer dedans
parce que c'est la même construction le
même gabarit que l'iphone 7 et le 8
par contre vous n'aurez pas la prise
pour le port jack vu que vous avez la
place pour un haut parleur mais si vous
en fichez du port jack si vous
n'utilisez pas ou peu votre smartphone
va quand même rentrer dedans
donc ça c'est plutôt cool et je trouve
que c'est franchement pas mal à larçay
ces résistants tout cas j'espère salaire
salaire à sallèles 10 ans ont participé
au concours je vous évite tous les liens
en bas directement ici dans la
description dont vous avez qu à les
jeter un petit coup d'oeil vous verrez
ya un petit formulaire à remplir trois
fois rien et on fait de votre
participation est enregistrée je vous
tiendrai au courant et je vous dirai qui
a gagné directement dans une prochaine
vidéo donc ne vous inquiétez pas et pour
tous les perdants parce que forcément il
ya quelqu'un qui a gagné il y en a pas
non plus énormément pour les perdants
toujours plus de perdants que de
gagnants
vous avez néanmoins des codes de
réduction chez rhinochill si vous
intéresse pendant les deux semaines qui
vont suivre le début du concours vous
aurez -1% chirino chine et ensuite -10%
le code ces grottes
grrr c'est tout con vous allez aussi un
ghana la description pour aller sur le
site de rhinau shield voilà pour ce
petit concours j'espère qu'il vous fera
plaisir espère que vous serez très
heureux et très heureuse de pouvoir
tenter votre chance participer et puis
repartir index école parce que
franchement je vais vous dire un truc je
les trouve pas mal du tout je trouve que
c'est vraiment bien réussi
rino schild a fait un beau boulot et je
dois reconnaître que je suis satisfait
de vous les montrer
j'oubliais je suis pas à payer pour vous
les montrer il ya six mois pas de
rémunération s'est pas toutes les vidéos
sponsorisées mais néanmoins je trouve
qu'ils font du bon boulot
et voilà ils font du bon boulot en plus
de ça ils vous offrent des coques donc
et demander de plus
à côté de ça si vous avez des objectifs
rhinochill pasquino chiffre fait aussi
des objectifs pour aller filmer les
corps sont complètement compatible avec
donc là dessus vous êtes tranquille et
lâche un peu l'idiot
ajoutant derrière en disant absolument
rien mais elles sont protégées au choc
jusqu'à 3 mètres 50 bon là ça va je
croyais plutôt banal autre camp qui est
important et non des moindres elles sont
traitées sans bisphénol a sans bpa
il faut savoir que le bpa est un
perturbateur endocrinien potentiellement
cancérogènes là y'en a pas un point
plutôt positif
voilà pour ces coques rhinochill pour ce
concours je vous invite à aller voir
directement bas pour participer et
tenter votre chance merci à vous d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo merci de toujours
plus nombreuses seront plus nombreux sur
la chaîne me faisais top c'est dire
je vais maintenant aller me reposer
parce que je suis très fatigué merci à
vous à travers une jambe bastos
[Musique]